and finally new role to make America
great again we must build a wall but not
a wall on the border no the wall we need
to build is between our work life and
our home life and we better do it soon
because our choices for president or a
guy whose catchphrases you're fired and
a woman whose husband made the interns
blow him
so I just got back from a week off and I
was amazed at the number of people I saw
who couldn't leave their work at work
they're on their laptops at the airport
and on their iPads at the beach some are
even on their secretaries at the hotel
but the beach shouldn't be a place to
catch up on invoices there used to be
some separation here you'd go to work
and do what you do to make a living then
you'd come home and do the living part
that's why when the horn sounded Fred
Flintstone yelled yabba-dabba-doo but in
the United States of always on the clock
there's no more disconnecting from the
workplace because the workplace is in
your pocket I see parents telling their
kids put the phone down you're missing
out on life but at least your kid is
using the phone to have sex with
strangers
you're using it to go over sales figures
81% of American workers say they conduct
work outside of work hours and 10% say
they've checked their email during sex
was it good for you honey yeah I cleared
out my inbox you know
there used to be this concept called out
of pocket your time off was just that
off and if your boss needed something
you had to wait till the next day
until he saw you taking your work home
with you meant you stole office supplies
but now no one wants to unplug because
they know that any time you're not
available someone else will be probably
that intern who's eyeballing your job
and who's planning to get it by using a
strategy called having no life I used to
think tech firms were cool because all
those workplace perks they offered you
know Facebook has a gym and a dry
cleaners in a doctor's office and if you
work at Google you get free massages and
they have a barber shop and a bank and
Rock Climbing Walls everything but a
stripper pole you can even bring your
dog to work but then if you didn't bring
your dog to work it would die because
you're always at work that's why they
provide meals and laundry service and
bunk rooms these aren't perks they're
Google's way of saying you live here now
Oh
oh look they gave us a ping-pong table
yeah and I once gave my hamster a wheel
and my turtle had a little plastic
island with a palm tree on it but it
didn't make it a worker's paradise if
you have this thing which is called a
snap into hammock that fits under your
desk it means your boss owns you
the same goes for the wearable futon air
mat and the full head desk pillow those
are real the State Department prints on
its website a list of ways to tell if
you're a victim of human trafficking and
the top three are living with employer
inability to speak alone and answers
appear scripted and rehearsed if that's
you you may be an intern in corporate
America or
or worse dating Taylor Swift
but here is something hopeful about this
France hey perfect friends just passed
the law this year that a search that
workers have a right to quote disconnect
they actually wrote a law that makes
companies they wrote a law that makes
companies set aside hours when employers
aren't allowed to email you because
Europeans have lives first and then go
to work here we can't enjoy our personal
lives without the boss sticking his nose
in and if you work at Fox News it might
be more than his nose he's sticking it
but if the Democrats are serious about
winning back the middle-class voter here
is your issue no email on the weekends I
have a feeling even Hillary could get
behind that one